hey I'm Adam Devine I'm Rob Wilson and
I'm Priyanka Chopra and we're doing the
wired autocomplete interview later fuse
[Music]
all right some people think I'm not nice
I think I think it is yeah we concur I'm
at times chained us is rebel Wilson
British no you fools I'm Australian okay
and rebel that wasn't very nice related
what Wilson and we both blonds naturally
we are not related okay is rebel Wilson
left-handed yes see that's a question
everyone's asking is rebel Wilson a good
singer not a Dell level no but great and
activist things good for an actor who
sings yeah I'm a little worried about
these admittedly is Adam Patrick Devine
they went with my full name this just
shows how much my mother looks up my
name on Google my full name what all
right there's Adam Patrick Devine
related to Jack Black and I do get that
quite a bit we have the same exact face
and body no we're not but he did play my
dad slash brother on workaholics weird
episode check it out
is Adam Devine single so we ladies and
and a dude's I got a girlfriend of four
years what's up Chloe is Adam Devine
actually singing in pitch perfect no
that was uh sure I
Merson bubbles uh sure did all know it
was me you don't have money to pay for
uh sure to come and sing my songs no is
me thank you for thinking I need an
actual singer to come in is Adam Devine
related to Sean Astin from Rudy and
Goonies I actually got a driver the
other day like an uber driver he was
like you're an actor right man and I'm
like uh yeah and he was like child actor
and I go oh and before I could answer he
goes I loved you in the Goonies The
Goonies I was I think I was like half a
year old when that movie came out okay
is Adam Devine Warren Buffett is that a
question am i Warren Buffett I mean I
don't I'm not the second richest man in
the world it also is 85 years old and
the only reason they're thinking that is
cuz he's from Omaha and I'm also from
Oman or maybe I just give off airs of
the winds
I'm later fuse is Priyanka Chopra a
princess yes I feel like yours are gonna
be much nicer I didn't want the world to
know because like my character in this
movie I'm a role model yeah yeah
[Music]
is she a singer well some people think
so I think so sometimes but it really
depends not around this lot who do it
professionally is Priyanka Chopra little
Deepak Chopra no question that that is a
question that I get very often but
Chopra is like Smith in India it is very
very common
okay um so no we don't know each other
at all yes because you're married to
Nick Jonas yeah also you're not very
good at using Google like yeah it's a
very search people new Numa baguette
yeah it was probably on the front page
you didn't even need to type in having
it least Bianca's over older than me yes
I am by 10 years actually
couger is Priyanka Chopra Miss Universe
no I was Miss World mm and you should
Google app oh we're going with does now
how does rebel Wilson have an Oscar no
but after this movie yeah I wish I'd
love I love to win an Oscar did Robert
Wilson sing in pitch perfect yeah you
see in pitch perfect yeah it's all about
real voices we had such a fun time how
did rebel Wilson become famous a lot of
hard work and talent and talent that's
how it happens who is rebel Wilson's
boyfriend vishal boyfriend right at this
moment so just don't have a child no but
I have a little niece never been married
never had kids yeah that I know of I do
how did Adam Devine get famous
I would I would have liked to I did
comedy I did stand-up and then sketch
and then I got it my own TV show so it's
easy to do it
blankety-blank Adam Devine that's my
name how we met Adam Devine seemed how
we met how how who met okay guy get
better at using Google when we first met
as a movie I did and maybe they're just
very bad googling things how did Adam
Devine and Chloe bridges meet we even
actually met on the set of a movie
the final girls which thomas troelsen
our director of isn't it romantic
directed at movies so
yep blankety-blank how old is Adam
Devine 58 looking good keeping it all
together I'm 35 years old just had my
birthday a couple months ago and I'm
falling apart is Priyanka Chopra vegan
mmm I know it's better for us but no
like talking about like I don't like
eating in front of them is Priyanka
asthmatic yes I am I do have my inhaler
with me all the time
did you know is Priyanka hindi hindi is
a language I'm Hindu which is the
religion it's a slight difference to
educate yourself no I'm not I'm
right-handed I got a speed round okay
what was rebel Wilson's
first job a tennis coach mu my uncle's a
tennis coach and I worked for him
what does rebel Wilson look like this
what is rebel Wilson favorite color
purple like royal purple what is rebel
Wilson doing now you guys I'm gonna
press junket there's no romantic what is
it rebel Wilson's phone number speed
round
Adam Devon where is Adam Devine from
Waterloo Iowa then I moved to Omaha
Nebraska when I was 10 then I moved to
LA where did Adam Devine go to high
school Millard South High School Omaha
Nebraska
why did Adam Devine eat the apple why
did Adam eat the apple not about me and
yeah it's good for you good for your
digestion does Adam Devine sing
sometimes in movies a lot of times in
the shower
did Adam Devine actually audition for
the voice the answer is no but I did in
pitch perfect to sing at the end yeah
for the voice hey speed as Priyanka
Chopra sing some people think so some
people don't
does Priyanka Chopra havoc
not yet but I would like to have one
this is Priyanka Chopra have tattoos yes
one and it's my dad's handwriting that's
daddy's little girl what school does
Priyanka Chopra speak Italian no I was
gonna say does Priyanka Chopra on a
rolls-royce yeah I do
where is it in Mumbai it's like the
colour of Pepsi silver tea that's so
opposite it was like her Liberty story
yeah that is the end of our wired
auto-complete interview very much
watching ennum please correct those
answers online if you do this they're
actually really interesting come on now
come with those hot cues questions